[Musique]
elles sont étudiantes cadre de
professions libérales et elle boit de
plus en plus c'est la statistique qui le
dit elles sont en france plus d'un
million qu'ils doivent au point de ne
plus pouvoir vivre sans alcool
mais qu'est ce qui les fait boire et ça
vous avez vu leur compte ou pas non
cette de verre trois verres cadref on va
c'est une bouteille et demi à deux avec
mon ami plus un petit buzz et alcool
parce que c'est vrai que le vin c'est
pas ça que je préfère quand alcool est
arrivé
je me suis senti mieux beaucoup mieux
pour moi j'envisage pas de
de passer une bonne soirée sans alcool
rapidement je pourrais devenir une
alcoolique
si je n'avais pas justement cette
vigilance est d'être sûr de pouvoir
maîtriser si je bois beaucoup
d'une part je vais prendre des kilos et
des kilos de kilos et d'autre part je
vais avoir des vaisseaux qui éclate je
vais avoir une tête qui va se défraîchir
et j'approche la quarantaine et là ça
devient dangereux
j'aime un peu être
quelqu'un d'autre je suis moi mais
désinhibé j'ai l'impression quand même
que je peux dire plein de choses vous
faire plein de choses que je pourrais
pas faire sans sans boire
ça a commencé chez mes parents
à table je ne supportais pas alors j'ai
constaté que un petit fond de verre qui
se passait beaucoup mieux je les
entendais plus et ça a fait pas mal leur
pas comme ça puis il s'agit quel age of
18 10 9 en quoi j'étais en hypokhâgne
faisait passer le bac
et puis après je rentrais dans ma
chambre et puis je me suis aperçu j'ai
quand même que que j'avais du mal à me
mettre au boulot en fait sa mue pour
pour me remettre et et j'étais bien et
quand je me suis retrouvé à 11 heures du
matin complètement victor et je me suis
dit que que la fallait sans doute faire
quelque chose ça être dans les études ou
ça je crois que ça aide beaucoup
enfin à partir du moment n'est pas
complètement abrutis hier et quand on a
trouvé la dose qui permet de qui aident
je crois qu'il ya dans l'alcool il ya un
moment où commencent et étendue il ya un
moment euphorique où justement ça et
d'au maximum et après il ya le moment
une abrutie vous savez plus alors en
langues
bon je faisais de l'allemand je
connaissais toutes les règles de
grammaire parker et toulouse vraiment
bien mais pour réussir vraiment à parler
à vero 2 ça allait je parlais beaucoup
mieux allemand quand j'avais acheté de
l'alcool pour une fin c'est pas toujours
facile ça va
sauf que par exemple quand il m'en
fallait
deux fois par jour j'ai changé
d'épicerie parce que quand même 2 litres
de bière pose de personnes en une
journée le week-end j'essaie de m'en
acheter un peu d' avance tout en ne
voulant pas en acheter trop enfin de
toute façon je pouvais tout tout de
suite
alors le problème c'était lundi parce
que le lundi il ya beaucoup d'épicerie
qui seront fermés puis chez était à
cours et c'est quand même là que je me
suis rendu compte que leilani il m'en
fallait qu tu t'es pas une alcoolique
classique mais je pense que que mes
relations avec l'alcool sont pas nettes
du tout
quand ce qu'ont à savoir en principe je
n'arrête pas faudrait absolument pas que
je touche à une goutte d'alcool et ça en
même temps je sens le moment en tout cas
je peux pas m'en empêcher
donc ça peut évidemment c'est quand même
un aspect assez angoissant pour l'avenir
bon parce que c'est ça devient carrément
une fois tous les trois jours
ça devient invivable là c'est la pente
c'est la déchéance carrément c'est bon
parfois j'ai bon ça arrive à tout le
monde de croiser des clochards et pris
de boisson dans la rue mais des fois
j'ai un choc bon surtout envers les
femmes parce que c'est vrai que les fans
c'est une déchéance physique
de toute façon on accepte moins
[Musique]
fissiles quelquefois de d'arrêter pour
rentrer chez soi et se retrouver
quelques fois dans la solitude bon et là
ça peut effectivement un petit peu
dépassé m'enfin jamais très loin quand
même vos enfants vous ont vu quelquefois
un peu pompette oft est arrivé oui on
éprouve quoi dans ces cas-là vis-à-vis
d'eux hausse non ça me gêne pas parce
que bon ils ont vu d'autres gens ils
n'ont pas à aviser même si que je devais
pas du tout envie de leur donner l'image
de quelqu'un avec une auréole sur la
tête et d'une sainte moi j'ai toujours
vécu ma vie telle qu'elle était je me
suis jamais gêné vis mes enfants et
j'ai des souvenirs
claire comment tout ça a commencé
tout ça a commencé pendant mon
adolescence ont porté haut fonctionnaire
j'avais souvent l'occasion d'assister à
des vernissages des cocktails à des
réceptions ce signifiait donc un ou
plusieurs verres de champagne ou de
whisky
j'aimais bien ça et cela me donnait de
l'assurance c'est un médicament contre
ma timidité
au début les premières années je n'en
consommait que chez moi au repas même
quand j'ai vécu seul après après un
mariage qui était très brefs et que je
me suis installé seul dans un studio
seul jamais prendre quelques verres de
vin avec leur pas un apéritif avant puis
il m'a fallu l'alcool dans la journée au
repas midi
j'avais hâte d'arriver à l'heure du
déjeuner bientôt ça n'a pas suffi alors
j'ai importé une flasque dans mon sac à
main puisqu'il whisky oui je me cachais
pour boire j'allais aux toilettes pour
boire un beau jour j'ai pris l'alcool le
matin en me levant ce que j'étais
angoissé je vais perdre aller au travail
et j'ai bu un fond de verre de whisky et
de jour en jour
le fond de verre de whisky est devenu de
plus en plus de plus en plus grands et
les quantités d'alcool que emporté au
bureau devenait de plus en plus grande
également la flasque n'a bientôt plus
suffi emporté une bouteille entière se
devenait dangereux j'ai fini par mettre
de la vodka ce moment là parce que lui
ce qui se voyait un peu trop je mettais
la vodka dans les bouteilles de vichy ou
déviants j'aime persuaderait moi même
que personne au bureau ne s'en rendait
compte
puis est arrivée la catastrophe
j'ai perdu deux emplois consécutif à
cause de l'alcool le premier emploi je
n'avais pas encore été trouvée ivre
véritablement au bureau mais le second
il a fallu me transporter dans un autre
bureau parce que j'étais ivre morte est
en fête l'alcool oui ça rejoint cela en
ce sens que ça signifie pour moi ce
moment là la liberté
je ne savais pas que ce que je croyais
être une liberté allait devenir pour moi
le plus terrible des esclavages nous est
fait piéger
oui je me suis fait piéger
quand même
l'intention de m
il vous fallait payer chaque fois que
vous buvez savons tous très combien à
peu près par jour là là c'est à dire que
comme je vois que le soir dans des
endroits nocturne où les verres d'alcool
sont assez chers je pense je n'ai pas
calculé mais que dans une soirée
parfois ça pourrait revenir je ne sais
pas on verra quand je pense au vert dans
les boîtes non c'est faux je n'ai pas à
1000 francs peut-être je sais pas qu'est
ce qui vous ferait arrêter
peut-être un enfant me fera arrêter
parce que ça vraiment c'est quand je me
pose la question c'est vraiment une
image que je supporterai pas d'être
saoul devant un enfant c'est vraiment
une image qui m'est intolérable est a
priori j'ai pas d'enfant donc priori ça
je pense que c'est vraiment pour un
enfant je ferai je pourrais arrêter
les derniers temps c'est à peu près 1 2
hommes en filets de lloris qui pour être
bien vrai de quoi la descente et bronze
de descente
et puis
deux mois avant d'arrêter en fait j'ai
décidé de j'ai décidé de supprimer
toutes les bouteilles de la maison et là
je me suis rendu compte que j'étais
vraiment accro parce que j'avais des
tremblote pas possible et chercher de
l'alcool partout en fait j'ai téléphoné
à ma petite maman chérie qui habite à
côté je disais j'ai des copains qui sont
de passage tu veux pas de dépanner d'une
bouteille de blanc que je m'enfile est
allègrement tout seul est tranquille et
puis le 19 19 mais ma fille m'a fait une
réflexion à 90 juste avant de sortir
avec des copains je m'étais enfilé
vraiment une bonne dose une bonne rasade
de whisky elle est passée à côté puis
elle me dit mais ça suffit
alors là j'ai vu j'ai vu vraiment mon
avenir je me suis dit c'est la fin ne
présentera jamais ses amis maires à
l'e.coli poivrote
j'ai dit il ya eu le premier déclic déjà
parce qu'on les brûle en moi j'ai prouvé
beaucoup de haine et beaucoup de dégoût
vraiment pour moi même parce que j'ai vu
ma fille qui se rendaient compte de cela
et je me suis dit qu'est ce que je vais
lui proposer je suis séparé ton papa est
parti les photos je les quitter en
partie à cause de 16% dans un bistrot là
et des gens 2 qui doit beaucoup d'autres
femmes lavent autour de nous je crache à
la toile ah oui ça me donne vraiment un
peu mais ça veut pas dire parce que je
ça me tente mais je le ferai pas parce
que je sais que ça entraînerait 10
derrière sur ce double aveugle aux
discussions
donc ça toute façon j'ai dit le jour où
je bois un verre je me flingue ça c'est
clair et net
[Musique]